müssen wir jetzt vielleicht noch mal
gucken
ok heute ist recht heiß draußen
das sind alles obstsorten die sind sehr
anfällig auf wärme
wenn man hier nicht immer laufend
kontrollieren kann es gut sein dass wir
in einer stunde ganz viele obst liegen
wäre ganz schön wenn du dann gleich mal
drüber guckst wirklich 100 prozent
müssen immer darauf achten dass ihr
immer alles hundertprozentig frische ja
alles klar darüber ja alles klar
wenn mal was man auch mir fällt gerade
auch die rems jetzt einfach nur davor
er muss schon ein bisschen so start um 8
98 12 da hinten dann wieder andere daten
dann musst du ein bisschen aufpassen
dass du hier den 12.08 nicht davor angst
was ja erst die alte ware nach vorne und
die neue dann dahinter
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir gleich eine bestellung
gerät ist auch schon so weit eingestellt
wo wir darauf achten müssen dass wir
hiermit ein lesen mit dem bilden gelben
knopf das ist okay
so
das nimmst du das mde gerät nur selber
in die hand ja mal mit dem knopf machst
du die bestellung mit dem scanner dann
an das etikett die post auch nichts
ändern da vorne
genau 1 du brauchst nichts machen du
brauchst kein unterdrücken was jetzt
nicht mehr bestätigen du kannst immer
wieder weiter an dem er in q3 angehen
und dann einfach bestellen so jetzt
prüfen wir mal eben vorne den
lieferanten einfach mal auch nicht in
was beschädigt
so wie zeige ich dir gerne mal wie wir
der kontroll vorgang ist kontoliste
weckt beim auspacken
du kannst dann falls was für ihn sollte
direkt anrufen mit viel klarer
das funktioniert auch so so ich brauche
dann bitte aber nur unterstellt alles
klar
unschön